allora katia già te lo dico che voglio
fare proprio proprio top leung e oggi
allora la forma a mela fi appuntava un
po arrotondata
le voglio appunto ma quadrate hai capito
come le voglio come non l'hai capito ci
sono lo capisci più grossa di lavoro ti
faccio vedere una foto che meglio quest
a si chiama ballerina fame la ballerina
poi mele fi rosse però di un rosso
capitò unconventional potrà le righe li
fai vedere quelli che hai sincera non mi
piace a nessuno ma perché non c'è
proprio quella tonalità rogo specifica
che cercavo io che a metà tra rosso
netto il sei rosso coca cola capito
vabbè allora fan big baby boomer ma come
te lo dovevo dire prima da mito policia
vaglio era allora mettimi una roba
neutra quello blu che brillanti di fuchs
ativo allora sincera bello però non mi
sta bene però poi cambiare ho capito che
un altro appuntamento ma se non mi piace
ma vero file prossima volta vado da mia
cugina che è molto più brava a me fa
pure gratis ma pensata